[Musique]
c'est un parcours ou multiples embûches
où il y a beaucoup d'appelés et peu
d'élus d'abord décrocher un poste dans
la fonction publique ensuite gravir les
échelons au sein de ministère pour
finalement atteindre le sommet un poste
de cadre supérieur bonjour
Valérie ben comment ça va ce cheminement
avocate l'a entamé en 1999 j'ai rentré
comme stagiaire
j'étais prêt à travailler fort j'ai
travaillé fort le 10 février elle a
écrit une page d'histoire elle est
devenue la première femme noire sous
ministre de la Justice et sous procureur
général du Canada honnêtement j'étais
complètement émue à cette toute une
honneur d'être nommé à ce poste là c'est
une grosse responsabilité c'est une un
moment historique pour moi pour ma
famille et je pense pour les Canadiens
des Canadiens
à quelques coins de rue on retrouve
Marjorie Michel elle n'est pas
fonctionnaire mais elle occupe un poste
politique d'importance sur la colline
parlementaire chef de cabinet adjointe
du Premier ministre Justin Trudeau dans
son cas aussi elle est la première femme
noire à occuper ce poste c'est sûr que
c'est un poste évidemment surtout dans
le regard des autres de dire oh mon Dieu
tu es arrivé là oui c'est vrai mais
c'est d'abord un poste de service elle
regarde vers l'avant mais n'oublie pas
le chemin parcouru elle raconte avoir
été confrontée à du racisme et de la
discrimination au travail je dirais que
c'est toujours plus
subtil
je le vois
mais j'avance alors j'ai commencé au
sein de la fonction publique dans les
années 1090 alors
c'était un environnement différent pour
moi c'est vraiment de faire de mon mieux
de regarder ce qui m'entoure et je
reconnais lorsque les systèmes ne sont
pas juste mais de ancrer à ma
personnalité ma confiance dans ce que je
suis capable à faire
si ces deux femmes ont réussi à
progresser en dépit des obstacles un
groupe allègue que des milliers de Noirs
ont vu leur progression bloquer au cours
des 50 dernières années dans la fonction
publique en raison du racisme systémique
et de la discrimination selon les
données compilées par le groupe recours
collectif noir sur les 6717 cadres
supérieurs dans la fonction publique 150
sont noirs hommes et femmes confondus
c'est moins de 2% des effectifs
2020 les plaignants ont déposé une
demande d'action collective en cours
fédérale ou non de ses employés fédéraux
sans commenter le dossier puisqu'il est
devant les tribunaux la sous-ministre
reconnaît qu'il y a du travail à faire
j'ai une responsabilité je pense à ma
communauté puis à tous les Canadiens de
normaliser à le fait que les femmes
noires pour accéder des postes qui sont
importants et qui ont un rôle important
dans notre société
mon avis honnête le mentorat fait donc
partie de la solution quand même celle
du cabinet à jouer d'avoir des
conversations avec ces femmes pour leur
donner de la place pour savoir c'est
quoi les enjeux et c'est tout le monde
ensemble qui annonce sur la table moi
parfois juste un véhicule
Charline et Marjorie Michel sont fiers
d'avoir ouvert la voie ce qu'elle
souhaite pour la suite c'est que
d'autres femmes comme elles rejoignent
leur rang
[Musique]